I want to talk a little bit about book
Banning one of the comments that I'm
seeing pretty regularly on the shorts
YouTube shorts that I post about
Republican book Banning efforts is
people commenting and saying Banning
these books is good because they're only
Banning pornographic books and books
that aren't age appropriate let me show
you some of the comments that I've been
receiving
uh the I won't even name the P these are
just YouTube people with long strings as
their usernames but here are some of the
comments how is Banning a porno book on
a middle school library fascism isn't it
at worst censorship based on age and at
best parenting and protecting children
from losing their innocence sooner than
necessary it's not fascism if it's
inappropriate content for kids
schlock of God says no Banning books
that are not appropriate for kids is
morally correct JP music says there's a
huge difference between limiting what
book schools can have available for kids
and removing books from public libraries
or not allowing the sale of certain
books JD says have you looked at the
content of the books many are
pornographic in nature Dr Ox says it
depends on what books are being banned
um Planet positivity says false when it
applies to children extremists on the
far left and right want their propaganda
talk to kids and both are age
inappropriate Jan says it's critical
that parents be able to make these
decisions I don't want the government
deciding what my kid can and can't read
but Billy beans said restrictions
imposed by parents are equally bad as
restrictions imposed by governments if
not worse Jay says Banning books is not
the same as removing non-age appropriate
books from elementary school libraries
so I decided to look at some of the
books that are being banned and you can
easily find these these lists penn.org
has a list and here's some of the books
that are regularly banned one is called
genderqueer a memoir
and it's about a person who uses
pronouns like air
and explains why to their family this
one's been banned more than 40 times all
boys aren't Blue by George Johnson which
is a series of essays from
um an LGBT activist that explores his
childhood and Adolescence out of
darkness by Ashley hope Perez a
dangerous forbidden romance rocks a
Texas oil town in 1937 when segregation
was a matter of life and death The
Bluest Eye by Toni Morrison because it
obsesses it examines our obsession with
beauty and Conformity and you can go
through these and you can get a bigger
list and this is going to be sort of
hard to see because of the zoom but you
see that there are all these different
books that have been banned some have
been banned by administrators some have
been challenged by parents you see all
these different examples and I have to
tell tell you I spent time randomly
picking these books and I went to Amazon
and I did the look inside and I read you
know a number of pages that are
available the vast majority of these
books are neither pornographic nor
extreme however many of them do have
story lines that it seems many right
Wingers don't like sometimes there are
gay characters
that's it so they want the book banned
sometimes there are descriptions of
sexual encounters and we could have a
conversation is that appropriate for
seven-year-olds well maybe not but is it
appropriate for high school juniors yeah
it's fine in some of them there are
descriptions of non-binary people or
whatever the case may be the
overwhelming majority of these books are
not pornographic and
it is very clear that a lot of the
people saying it's good to ban these
books have absolutely no idea what is in
the books I also want to say another
thing a lot of these books don't seem
that great to me and what I mean by this
I'm not saying
a lot of this stuff is just personal
preference at the end of the day right
like what kind of stuff do you enjoy
reading a lot of these books as I look
at them aren't particularly titillating
but they also don't seem particularly
interesting to me and it seems to me
that making a big deal for any reason
out of these books just doesn't really
make sense if this is a book that a
teacher wants to have in a curriculum it
just seems very strange to get all
shaken up about it and what I was
reminded of of course is that the right
Wingers that want a lot of these books
banned are really the snowflakes they
love to say oh the left is so sensitive
the left can't handle anything and all
these different things I mean listen uh
gay relationships exist
slavery existed brutality existed uh
non-binary people exist and just saying
that the inclusion of that those as
topics is quote inappropriate for quote
kids particularly when a lot of them
don't distinguish between a first grader
and a High School junior or senior they
seem to be exposing themselves as the
snowflakes that can't handle any
anything and you know I don't want to
like go too far down this path but if
you look at historical efforts to ban
you know so-called degenerate art as
Nazis wanted to do if you look at all
other efforts that we've seen over time
from authoritarian leaning movements and
leaders to control media and books and
Publications it's really ugly stuff and
quite frankly it mostly seems to
backfire so take a look at the books
that they actually want to ban go on
Amazon click on look inside look read a
little bit and you will very quickly see
that this is not actually about banning
porn